hey
[Music]
so sorry everybody for the delay i was
great i uh i arrived today at furman and
i saw the campus i was able to walk
around a little bit before we started
and it's uh it's very beautiful i was
really happy to discover this place
um
so i'm an i'm an orthodox icon carver as
as you heard you can see these are my
these are a few examples of my works up
there but i'm actually not going to talk
about my work i'm not going to talk
about icon carving i'm actually going to
talk mostly about
monsters
and i'm going to talk about
what monsters
mean and how they let's say
fit in the in the world and i was given
a title i didn't choose the title i
don't even remember what the title is
but it's like it's like zombies versus
icons what is it art
and and the apocalypse or something so
yeah so i am going to talk about art i
kind of
weave that through hopefully everything
will come together and and make sense uh
but as an artist and as someone who has
been studying christian art for a long
time i'm
very interested in christian symbolism
and as a student of symbolism and also
as an artist i'm very sensitive to
cultural images which appear
on our cultural horizon let's say
and so one of the things that i've
noticed and i think most people have
noticed is that we we live in a time of
monsters
it seems that since the beginning of the
20th century
the the horizon of our storytelling
storytelling let's say the narrative
level of our culture is filling up with
levels that it's almost difficult to
fathom with images of the monstrous
and it's been going on going on for
quite a while and it has accelerated
quite a bit
in the last
few decades
and the monsters they've moved away from
the stories of fear from the horror
stories and they've made their way into
the most comfortable places
even into our children's stories
and for those i'm 42 and for those who
are my age and maybe a bit older a bit
younger we grew up with with sesame
street and
which told us that monsters were our
friends
and so let's let's be honest the world
our world is obsessed with monsters
with things that are strange with aliens
with things that are marginal with
glorifications of the exception things
that are in between things that don't
fit
if we remove the moral
interpretation of the monster let's say
if we we're not i'm not here to talk
about good or bad um if we look rather
at the technical definition of a monster
in fact a monster is something that does
doesn't fit
it's something that doesn't fit within
the usual categories of the human
experience monsters are too big they're
too small they have too much or too
little of something too many arms too
many heads
just one eye just one foot
or else they're a mixture a mixture of
different categories a mixture of
different animals or a mixture of humans
and animals and ultimately
let's say the ultimate monster might be
the confusion between life and death
the mixture between life and death the
ghost
the vampire and the zombie
but we'll get to the zombie
pretty soon
so the monster is is a
is a breakdown of meaning
it's a place where categories fall apart
they are the exceptions and they appear
on the edge of meaning
and in the ancient world monsters were
seen as signs in fact the word monster
means a warning
a portent
in french it's has the same word as the
same root as the word montre which means
to show
in english we still have the word
demonstrate which has the word monster
inside of it
but the idea of showing in terms of the
monster really needs to be understood in
the sense of this warning this portent
and the question is what is the monster
warning us about
there's a scene in the uh
the romance of alexander the great and
for those who don't know these are
legends of the life of alexander the
great and they're actually very
important in the uh the western canon
let's say uh and for some reason i don't
even know why those stories are
important from for from england to
greece you find them in uh in the middle
east in persia all the way in israel all
the way to india they all have their
versions of these legends of alexander
the great and they're really important
in terms of understanding world
cultural world history and for some
reason they
they're they're being forgotten uh in
our time and so this image is is is a
cup is a cover of a book but you can see
that it's actually a persian miniature
of alexander the great sitting on his
horse who's coming to meet the brahmin
in india who are seen as the naked
philosophers and so in the legend legend
of alejandra the great the the brahmin
were didn't wear any clothing and they
were seen as this kind of pure knowledge
they didn't have any belongings
[Music]
and so there is this uh
in the legend of alexander the great
there's a story of a woman who gives
birth to a stillborn monster
this is a byzantine
image of of that story
and so the monster
the stillborn monster that is born is a
human from the waist up
but is a mixture of different animals
from the waist down
and the human part was dead
but the different animal parts are still
moving
described as being like the great
monster cilla
which we hear of in homer's odyssey that
is this multi-headed serpent uh but this
writhing uh spaghetti has the
characteristics of leopards lions wolves
wild boars and dogs
human above the waist
but a writhing octopus
uh
of conflicting beasts below the waist
and i'm sure i'm sure most of us have
experienced that once in a while
so the woman
she runs to alexander with this
monster
and with that when alexander sees the
child he knows that it's a sign but he
doesn't know
what it what what it is a sign of and so
he calls the chaldean magicians he
called the chaldean wise men to
interpret this sign and although some
actually tried to hide the meaning of
the sign to alexander there is one of
the magicians who tells them the truth
with fear and trembling he tells them
that
quote oh bravest of all men
you are the human body and the wild
animal forms are the soldiers who are
with you
if the human part of the body were alive
and moving as are the animals beneath it
you would have been destined to rule all
men
but it is the very part that is dead and
the beasts are alive
so just as it has left its living state
so have you two departed
for example the animals that are bound
to the human body have no kind of
consideration towards man in the same
way to those who surround you
not love you and there will be many
upheavals in the world when you depart
and those about you will fall out with
one another and will bloodily slaughter
one
another what alexander encountered was
truly
a monster
and you could say that it is the
archetypal monster
you see the sign
the portent that the monster is showing
is nothing but what it is itself
the monster is the lack of a unifying
principle
right it is the harbinger of that state
a harbinger of chaos
the beasts which intermingle and fight
among themselves because they have lost
whatever it was that held their
multiplicity
into a coherent whole
and so here the conscious agent the
human part was dead and the beastly
chaotic parts were left to fight amongst
themselves
if you think of a person like a
hierarchy
hierarchy with the head as the chief
let's say and the lower parts the bottom
the edge the periphery of the body as
the as as the the edge of the body uh we
can see you know how the the breakdown
in this particular
image this image that alexander saw was
in fact
an omen of something larger it became a
cosmic image of what was going to happen
when alexander died and we know that is
what happened his empire immediately
began to fight amongst each other and to
fragment
so we can see
this sign the sign that alexander saw we
could see it at a social level we can
see it
the type of civil war that erupts when
the different factions of apology can no
longer agree on what unifies them
or we can experience it as
the conflict of our own
passions our own desires
you know which when we're no not able to
steer and manage those desires they
fight amongst each other and they rip us
apart they can destroy our lives they
can destroy our families they can
destroy our friendships and they can
even destroy our own human integrity
so we need to pay attention and pay
attention very carefully because the
obsession of the modern world but the
monstrous is no longer just in fiction
it's no longer just in stories in fact
the monsters have left the dark spaces
under our beds
they've left our nightmares and they've
come out
to play
and i think
we all feel
this loss of unity
we all feel this loss of meaning that is
creeping into our
societies
at the social level we can feel and we
can see all around this growing
polarization the acceleration of what we
can only call a strange breakdown
the decomposition of culture
the progressive dissipation of of any
center which can rally us as societies
and it's difficult not to come back to
the famous poem by yeets that poem that
we've heard a million times but that
it's worth to revisit i think it's the
poem that is the most cited in uh
in modern
uh poetry
turning and turning in the widening gyre
the falcon cannot hear the falconer
things fall apart the center cannot hold
mere anarchy is loosed upon the world
the blood dim tide is loose and
everywhere the ceremony of innocence is
drowned
the best lack all conviction while the
worst are full of passionate intensity
and this poem
is the most famous poem
of modern poetry because it rings so
true because we we stand here in what
feels like this white
gyre this acceleration of time
on the edge of the world where the wheel
is spinning so fast that sometimes it
feels like it's going to come off its
axis
and we can see that yeats is using the
same structure that we saw in
alexander's monster
the falconer
as the human agent
as the intelligent agent losing control
of the predatory beast which gets
farther and farther and farther from his
control
and things fall apart
and so here we stand on the edge it
sometimes seems
and it is here that we find
the zombies
wandering aimlessly in a world that is
losing its center
now the zombie
unlike the other ancient monsters the
other traditional monsters
it's truly a harbinger of contemporary
nihilism
the zombie at least the 20th century
version of it the the recent version of
it it has no magic right it's a rival is
an accident some kind of freak event a
disease a plague
uh it has no reason that it it's caused
in a biological accident
the the zombie is just an animated
corpse
it it and it habits the indeterminate
space between
life and death living death
the zombie roams around in packs
and it shows us this mindless mindless
wandering of a mindless mob
with an insatiable hunger for devouring
others
for swallowing life itself
so if the vampire would be the monster
of aristocracy let's say the zombie is
truly the monster of the masses it is
the monster of the accidental
it's the quantitative leveling the
zombie is the ins is the atheist
insistent on the absence the illusion of
free will
and it is this image of nihilism and
idiosyncrasy taken all the way
to its extreme into decomposition
now
in almost every major city in north
america they have these events you might
have heard about them
they call them zombie walks
so people dress up
as zombies
and they they walk in thousands down the
streets dressed up to make up to make to
make them look like corpses
uh they shift around with dead empty
eyes pretending to be the walking dead
and some of these are
huge
if we were generous we could call it a
zombie procession maybe
we could say that they're
liturgical zombies
if there's such a thing
if you want to know what a society is
you simply have to look at what it
processes around
what makes it come together and process
it will give you an idea look at social
rituals
and so the zombie
typifies the mob yes but not
only the zombie also typifies the
absolute individualism the absolute
isolation of contemporary life because
the zombies they only interact with what
they desire they never interact with
each other
they're a mob but they're not a whole
they're not a community
and the trope of cannibalism
obviously that's a very ancient trope
it's it's just it's a trope that's been
there in the ancient stories from the
beginning we have them in so many
ancient myths but this tweak in the
zombie stories of eating the brains
is quite important
because the zombie
is a creature without meaning
without intelligent it misses any form
of person
and so it has this insatiable desire
which mirrors what it lacks
it desires what it lacks identity
meaning and this desire appears
you know as that it appears in that
materialist reduction of the of the
person to this clump of cells that we
have up in our cranium so the zombie
wants to eat your brains because it
cannot eat the mind because it cannot
speak the mind
but strangely enough the
desire to eat the living
it's the extreme perversion of our
desire for communion with each other
it's also a distilled image of all our
desires of all our passions let's say
because when we
let our desires
get out of control
we always see that we attempt to fill
this unquenchable yearning
what we do is we transform other people
into commodities we transform other
people into something that can get me
what i want
and so the zombie is both an image of
the social breakdown the person as a
meaningless statistic the disappearance
of common values except
the overwhelming desire to consume
but it's also the breakdown of the
person itself into a soulless desiring
death machine
and they're a very strict analogy
between those different levels of the
world the social breakdown and
polarization
is to the state with the the total
abandonment to our des of our desire to
consume and to our little idiosyncrasies
uh is to the person and the zombie
inhabits both of those things at the
same time
i gave a version of this talk last year
in chattanooga
tennessee and since i gave that talk
some of the people who
follow me on social media they pointed
me to a book who was that was written by
a university of toronto scholar
his name is john vervacu
vervaka
and it was published the same
near the same time that i gave this talk
last time and i was really amazed to see
in his book uh
how close our thoughts were how close
the the relationship of what i was
saying uh was to what he was saying um
and vervaka he mentions the
post-modernist theorists de los
ange those two people who work together
and he quotes them saying that the only
modern myth is the myth of the zombies
this is i think it's quite accurate and
i think it's increasingly
so because the zombie is precisely a
breakdown
in meaning
and long ago in my own studies i i
discovered that
the famous you know the father of
post-modernism uh he himself called
the living dead agents of deconstruction
quote
zombies are cinematic inscriptions of
the failure of the life death opposition
they show where classificatory order
breaks down they mark the limit of order
like all undecidables zombies infect the
oppositions grouped around them
so i hope you're used to hearing
post-modern theory by the way
the zombie is therefore fascinating and
also horrific
it poisons systems of order like all
undecidables it ought to be returned to
order
but this is difficult to do because the
zombie
is already dead
if
it is
dead and living at the same time so how
do you solve the zombie story
and it's not a simple task to do
diridah comes to the end it says the
zombie might be in irrequitable it might
it might be impossible to eradicate it
they might return
possibly undecidability is always with
us if not figured into zombie then
something else ghosts golems or vampires
between life and death
and i knew exactly what a monster is
and to be generous with him he wrote
this long before the zombie craze like
long before the the permanent impact of
george romero and the contemporary wave
of the nihilistic zombie before the
zombie hordes
which brought about cultural phenomena
like like the walking dead
in the modern zombie story there is no
solution to the zombie narrative not
really
someone tried to give us some relatively
happy endings but we all know that in a
zombie story you just survive as long as
possible
as what
calls the undecidables encircle you to
devour what is left of quote
classificatory order like civilizations
families friends and hire any hierarchy
of meaning
mere anarchy is loosed upon the world
and finally you are infected yourself
and the virus infects your own will with
the zombie state
and your own center cannot hold
your own narrative succumbs to the
mindless
wandering
and insatiable hunger
now
the cultural manifestations of our world
they have
meaning they are not arbitrary they are
signs they are important
of where we stand in the patterns of
history
i am a liturgical artist
and i and i'm trained in contemporary
art
and the signs of the monstrous and the
zombie apocalypse were there in fine art
before everywhere else
they're there within
the modern art world itself
i mean one needs to look no further than
picasso to see a breakdown
of the person
a breakdown of the point of view
the breakdown of meaning was already
there becoming clearer and clearer after
the stark realization of world war one
after the desperation of world war ii
the vision
that the hopes and dreams of progress
were then laid bare
in the millions of corpses slaughtered
and lying in mass graves
and we can see it develop how the
fragmentation of early cubism which you
see
as the first image
which almost looks mathematical as a
mathematical game now becomes more
frightening
breakdown as pica and picasso's later
images
and if you doubt that it's there picasso
if you doubt this breakdown this
breakdown makes itself seen in the later
waves of artists
what in picasso might for some seem like
just an exercise in visual exploration
is unveiled in someone like francis
bacon as
beaten deformed and decomposing flesh
anyone who has seen a zombie movie has
seen
this face
though bacon painted these
years before the zombies graced
our screens
i'm from montreal
and not too long ago the museum of fine
arts
uh in montreal they bought a church
you can see it in this image it's the
church that's right next to to the
museum they needed a
a church to ex they needed more space to
expand the collection so they bought
this church
and then they uh they gave a commission
to a canadian sculptor his name is david
achmed and he produced this for them in
front of the church
so
it's a it's a broken
down angel with a hole
for a heart
and with a kind of cancerous blob
weighing down its wings and the flesh
is coming off
uh
this his body you know to show us that
it's just a construction
and it's a it's a fallen angel
and we know that it's a fallen angel
because because athmet has made an
entire series on the subject of the
fallen angel or the giants in genesis
the nephilim the giant race of monsters
in in
in the predilution story
these are more of admits
work
and these these giants
these these monsters have a long history
in uh jewish and christian lore
and they were seen by some as a result
of the fallen angels that mixed with
human beings
and created these giant monsters
so the the professor i talked to you
about john vervaca
at university of toronto he has a pretty
interesting ideas about
the zombie
and he he tells us that quote
while the zombie is a versatile enough
symbol to stand for many kinds of human
defilement the symbol ultimately draws
its atmos from being a perversion of the
christian mythos of death and
resurrection
that most of its traits and features
have emerged from and hearkened back to
the matrix of the christian worldview
we will contend that the zombie has
evolved to become a representation of
the loss of the sacred canopy
traditionally provided by christianity
and that its features have evolved along
the fault lines of this lost
representing a world that no longer
explains itself
nor provides us instruction
for how to live within it
so when you hear that all of a sudden at
med's angel at med sculpture takes up
all
all the sense because
here we have a church that has been
basically
made hollow and changed into a
museum to show modern art
and in front of it is an angel with a
hollow heart and that is decomposing
so
yeah symbolism happens
and i agree i agree in large part with
vervaka i i
he he's not a christian at all he's
actually a secular buddhist and uh but i
i totally agree and so i i think maybe
we can look then we can look at just how
the christian world view and in many
ways uh the traditional world view of
many cultures how they make sense of the
monster
i think that our stories they can help
us understand
uh the world
our ancient stories if we can kind of
forget the the polemics that exist and
especially in american christianity
about
historical you know literal or whatever
all that stuff if we forget that and we
look just at the story we can see in
these story
some powerful patterns that can help us
view the world in a different way it can
help us view the world as we can see
these stories as a kind of map a map
that traces
patterns in life traces patterns in
history and this is especially true of
the early stories in the bible
so in the in the in the garden of eden
when adam and eve fall
god tells them that if they eat the
fruit of the knowledge of good and evil
he tells them that they will die
now
for the sake of our discussion you have
to to see this warning
in relation to the monster i mentioned
at the beginning of the story of
alexander the great
the monster with the dead human and the
writhing beasts that might seem a bit
strange to you but give me the benefit
of the doubt
also keep in mind the poem by yeats
describing this falcon this creditory
animal who no longer hears the command
of his master
and who whirls uncontrollably in the
widening gyre
you see god tells adam and eve that if
they eat the fruit they will die
but that's not really what happens it
that's not really what happens in the
story is it
right they eat the fruit but then they
don't die
and what happens is that god
chases them away from this central place
from this central tree he chases them
away and he starts to move out from this
axis of the world start to move away
and as they move away they encounter the
limit of the garden and they encounter
this cherub with a flaming sword which
guards the entrance
and as they move away god gives us god
gives them these garments of skin
and the garments of skin are these dead
covering of animal skins
and so you can see this moving out
from the center and then this adding of
layers and layers upon layers to each
other so god gives them these garments
of skin and in the in the church fathers
in the christian tradition these
garments of skin that are given to adam
and eve they're seen as not just the
garments of skin but they're seen that
everything that we add onto our nature
everything that we add on to to our to
our human nature so if that includes uh
it includes technology it includes
society it includes civilization
and so this idea that god gives them
these dead skins that are around them
and it's very strange because
why does why would god give them this
layer of death to protect them
as he's chasing them out of the garden
and
pondering that
thinking of this idea of a layer of
death which is placed around our nature
as we move out
further and further away from the center
is going to be the key to understanding
the possible meaning of the monster
and if you don't understand it right
away you can actually you can think
maybe just of what a vaccine is
a vaccine is made from
the the the disease that is trying to
cure you just like an anti-venom is made
from the venom that is trying to cure
you there is this relationship between
death uh and
this moving this this possibility of
being protected from death
and so in the bible
from the fall of adam to the flood right
it can be seen as this increasing this
adding on of layers and layers to the
descendants of atom as they multiply as
they spread out each furthering
layer
is provoked by some kind of fall in a
manner
a consequence of the fall so adam and
eve leave the garden
they fall they leave the garden then
cain kills his brother and then begins
the cycle of revenge
and it said whoever killed kills kane
will be avenged sevenfold
and then kane founds the first city
those things are not arbitrary
and as we
move further down the genealogy of kane
we find lamech who says
if cain will be avenged seven times i
will be avenged 77 times and we see this
increase in vengeance but we also see an
increase in technology
in the lineage lineage of cain in the
descendants of kane we find those who
now live in tents we find those who
develop musical instruments and finally
they develop weapons of iron
to
increase their possibility of war
and so as we move
further and further we have to imagine
it in the world
once again in the words of
the word of yeast this falcon moving out
further and further and layers and
layers of protection which prevent
humanity from seeing the heart seeing
the garden which now as cain is moving
further and further away from this
garden and this tree he can't see it
through all these layers and layers of
of uh of protection and increase
and as we get towards the end of that
then we get this idea of these crazy
mixtures this notion that the sons of
god went into the daughters of men
whatever exactly that means some people
think it means angels had relationships
with women other people think that it's
the the let's say the more pure people
who kind of mixed with these chaotic
crazy people it doesn't matter what what
what what exactly
it means what's important is to
understand that there's confusion
this confusion that comes at the end and
these monsters which appear on the edge
of history
and so these giants appear as the last
of this sequence of falls
and then
there's
the flood
and the giants
they were they were said
if you look at the traditions of the
giants you can get a lot of information
about what they mean
it was said about the giants that they
created chimera
that they like to create these hybrid
animals that had you know a beak of this
bird and feet of this animal and so
there is this idea of confusion which
comes and this confusion
is the very cause it is the very
uh
line which brings us to the flood which
is a return to chaos
which is a return to the chaos which was
there
at the beginning before creation this
chaotic sea in the chaotic waters
so in the same way we can see it in
history right you can follow the line in
history going from adam in the garden
all the way to the flood but we can also
see it in space
and so this story
it echoes how the ancients viewed the
world itself the ancients the ancient
greeks the ancient romans and in so many
other traditions they viewed the world
as this giant island
this giant island which was surrounded
by a vast and serpentine ocean
and on the edge of the world
is where
the monsters are
on the furthest reaches on the edge of
the ocean in a place where we can only
imagine is where the monsters lay
and so these are images of the ancient
of the monstrous races that were
described imagined who knows by pliny
the elder in the in roman times that who
live on the eastern edge of the world
so i always wonder what pliny would have
said
if if if he how he would have described
our own
far away specimens
now
we have to be i have to be careful we
have to be careful
i talked about the analogy between the
person and society and we have to
understand everything that i'm saying
applies as much to ourselves as people
as it does to society as it does to
history and so we find on the edges of
ourselves
the same thing the same conflict the
same chaos if we let ourselves go too
far into our own chaotic thoughts our
own chaotic feelings then we find the
same type of monsters that we would find
on the edge of the world i think we all
have noticed the zombie
growing in our own dark places
and so as a
as a christian
i i always go back to
to this promise that christ made
before christ left the world in the
story in uh in the beginning
in
in the gospels christ makes this promise
to his disciples he tells them i will be
with you until the end of the age
and so following the analogy we can we
can also imagine going to the end of the
age as going also to the ends of the
earth
being able to
his message being able to reach all the
way
to the edge
and so if you look at this this image
from vaseline in france it's actually a
a mixture of the ascension of christ
when christ told the disciples to go out
into the world and that he would be with
him until the end of the age and
pentecost
when
the fire of the holy spirit came down on
the disciples and
made them able to speak in all the
different languages of all the people so
if you look at the image you'll see
around christ the whole
ark around christ it's all these
different types of people all these
different types of people from all over
the world
and then around him again at the top are
all the signs of the zodiac and then
also all the seasons and so we have this
analogy of moving through to the edge of
time and also moving all the way to the
edge of the world
and in in the orthodox tradition
especially we we have this scent that
moving to the edge of the world
and this promise that christ made to
move all the way to the edge of the
world is also a promise to go to the
bottom of the earth to go to the bottom
of death
this is an image of
the
the resurrection which is actually an
image of christ descending into death
and going all the way to the bottom of
the world in order to find adam and eve
and pull them out of of death
i told you about this notion of the
garments of skin and this idea of the
vaccine this notion of death in in in
the orthodox tradition as we move
towards pasca we know at posca that we
will hear
that christ trampled down death by death
that there is a mystery about the edge
of the world there is a mystery about
the very bottom of the world which turns
which
flips and that is really the mystery of
how the end is transformed into a
beginning of how
death can change into a resurrection
now this cosmic shape that i mentioned
at the beginning these layers upon
layers upon layers
you know they were the structure not
only of the stories not only of the map
of the world but they were the structure
of the tabernacle
that the israelites built
they had a holy of holies and then they
had these layers of veils and the last
layer on the tabernacle was this garment
of skin just like adam had this garment
of skin protecting him
and then it was the image of the temple
and it is and it is still
the the same structure is still the
image of a church
a traditional church not a not a uh
let's say a rock concert hall a mega
church but let's say a traditional
church still has that structure that
cosmic structure of a center
which is the sanctuary the altar where
the clergy mostly are and then the nave
where the people gather and then the
narthex where not in that where anybody
can come and so in the old old ancient
tradition of the church there was
actually a time during the church
service where anybody who wasn't
baptized would actually have to
physically leave the nave of the church
and stand in the narthex because the
narthex was this transition space
between inside and outside this buffer
zone between between what is what is
inside and outside and so that might
seem
like a practice that many people would
disapprove of today and to be honest we
most churches don't do that today but if
you just think about if you just think
about your own house
you just think about your own family
you know our own houses are built in the
exact same way we have
people our friends who maybe can hang
out with us in the living room
acquaintances let's say then we have
closer friends who maybe will come in
and eat with us in our dining room
and then the strangers maybe they'll
stay in the in the entrance or maybe
they'll stay on the porch
but even your close friends usually
won't follow you into your bedroom
so there is a hierarchy of intimacy
which is the same hierarchy of intimacy
that you find in the church is the same
hierarchy that i've been describing
since the beginning as the very shape of
the world
now
this understanding this structure
understanding this basic structure can
help us
can help us understand uh
the great mystery that so many people
still struggle with today
is to understand what i hope that once i
when should i show you it'll become
obvious is to understand why exactly the
western church developed the tradition
of having gargoyles on the outside of
the church
it's not just in it's not just in in in
western churches there is also a
tradition in georgia which is which is
an eastern church it's an orthodox
church and they have a tradition which
is actually being revived today
where they have
griffins
outside of the church acting as these
guards
of the church
to me i actually wonder why in the world
would you not have gargoyles on the
outside of your church just seems like
the obvious thing to do once you start
to see this pattern and how the world is
made just seems like the obvious thing
to do to have gargles on the outside of
the church and it's just that's just the
shape of everything they had sphinxes in
egypt which were protected their holy
spaces and we have the cherub
you know that guards the holy of holies
and the chair that guards the
the garden of eden and if you read what
a cherub is
it is a
creature with
four wings and a head of a lion and a
head of a
human and the head of a bird and the
head of an ox and the legs of a bull and
so you have
this creature which protects the the the
holy of holies which is on the outside
and is and is either protecting or
acting as a mount
for the divine so there are images in
scripture where god is seen writing a
cherub across the sky or else god comes
down and appears on the cherubs which
were on the ark of the covenant as the
support as this this deceit for
the the divine
all of these things are the same
structure
now
it's important to understand this
because
you know i've mused about us being on
the edge and being obsessed with the
exception with the monstrous with the
chimera
but we have to understand that on the
edge of the world
there isn't just a monster
on the edge of the world there is also
a flaming sword
and i mentioned this when i talked about
this cherub that stands as the
gatekeeper of the garden of eden
so on the edge
of the world on the end of the world
there is a kind of radicalization
an aspect of the edge which is upside
down and confusion and desire
and there's an aspect of the edge which
is a final cut off
a wall
a sword
and the modern world has been a pendulum
between those two extremes
i mean in north america and in western
europe we just happen to be on the one
side on the desire side on the
the fragmenting side on the confusion
side possibly
but we can feel it and i think everybody
in this room can feel it teetering
towards that other extreme towards the
wall
and we've already seen the awakening of
this flaming sword in the 20th century
this desire for absolute
purity
a move to eliminate for good all that is
extra all that is marginal all that does
not fit
and if you think
one side cannot flip into the other you
are not paying attention to history
occam's razor can make some bloody cuts
when it is applied to society
in fact there is a trope in zombie
stories itself
which is that no matter how bad it gets
out there no matter how much the zombies
come and are clawing at the door are
coming to eat our brains no matter how
bad it gets the real danger is inside
the real danger is when the human group
cuts themselves off so much
becomes so isolated
that they become completely pathological
in their isolation
and so we should actually rejoice
to see the gargoyles to see them on the
outside of the church
to recognize these ambiguous
guardians standing at the limit of the
church showing us the role of the
ambiguous showing us the role of the
strange of those things that don't fit
and so as for that after the zombie
apocalypse the problem is not the
monster
not the strange not the it's not the
thing that doesn't fit into categories
which is the problem monsters have a
role to play in the grand scope of
things
just like our passions have a role to
play just like exceptions just like the
unknown
or
idiosyncrasies in the idiosyncrasies of
existence all of those have a part to
play that's not the problem
the zombie apocalypse happens when there
are more idiosyncrasies than there is
unity
when there are more exceptions to the
system than there are of the system
when that happens that is the very
description of decomposition
a rotting corpse comes about when the
elements cease to have unity and break
down into their
idiosyncratic directions
the problem of gargoyles would be if all
the saints in the church were replaced
with gargoyles
it's a turning upside down of the world
so let me give you an example
so if modern and postmodern art for
example
was there to break down the systems of
representation to question all the rules
all the presuppositions of art
then the zombie apocalypse
is when we have giant state-funded
museums filled only with art
that is supposed to question the rules
of art
can you see the problem with that
you can't be a rebel when everybody is a
rebel it just doesn't work it just falls
apart
in order to be a rebel you need
something solid to be standing outside
of and criticizing
so i want to present you one
monster
there is one monster in the in the the
western imagination
which has taken up a special place
that
monster is the xenocephalus
it is the dog-headed man
so dog-headed men actually appear
in
cultures all over the world from from
from england to china i mean they
they're they they're in every culture
but
at least in the christian tradition the
dog-headed man came to us from guess
where
it came from the legends of alexander
the great
and so here are here is alexander
fighting the dog-headed men
from a medieval manuscript
so the doghead and men became the very
image
of this fierce and undescribable
strangeness
the fierce and undescribable
foreigner
they are encountered as the very image
of the unknown
and they're hailed as the enemy of
christ and the enemy of civilization
itself
they are the ultimate barbarian
we could say
that they are
an image of chaos
they are an image
of the unknown in human form
that's a dog-headed man gargoyle by the
way
so just as the word barbarian
the word itself means someone who barks
like a dog right bar bar bar
so true that the xenocephalus you could
call that you could call it a visual
barbarian
and it's important to give
a caveat we don't have to imagine
we don't have to think we don't
even though some conspiracy theories
might like to do so we don't have to
think that there was actually ever or is
ever
a race of people that were a genetic
mixture of humans and dogs that's just
absolutely absurd that we
just as we don't have to think that a
hippopotamus
which means a river horse
has to have a genetic relationship to
horses ancient people just used
different categories they didn't we're
talking about genetics talking about
experience
so this experience of the unknown
the experience of a category of human
being that you can barely recognize
because they're so far away from your
capacity to see them
you know it's hard for us to imagine
that because now we've seen everything
but imagine you know 500 years ago
encountering an australian bushman
imagine the difficulty of recognizing
that person because you you're it's so
far away from your own experience you
can still have that experience today in
terms of sound you know if i
as a
english speaker east english speaker if
i hear a language like german and i can
kind of make out a little bit of it you
know and i and i can kind of hear some
words and pick out some words
if i hear something let's say like
russian
can't hear the words but i can make out
the intonations and i can kind of get a
sense of at least
where they're going but when i hear
cantonese i hear chaos i don't can't
make out any of it
so we can have that experience of
auditory chaos you just have to imagine
the experience of
a visual chaos let's say um
and so
so the ancient
so for example so the the the dog-headed
men you have to see them they're not an
actual group of people
they're just a type they're they're a an
image of this encounter with something
undescribable so if uh if alexander
found the dog-headed man in
in in on the edges of asia charlemagne
found the dog-headed man's as these
northern barbarian tribes coming down to
kill his men and then christopher
columbus thought he found the dog-headed
men when he arrived in north america
it's just that experience
of
the absolute difference
so in a way the sinocephalus became the
typical monster of the middle ages
but i want to show you something
so in the image i showed you before this
image i showed you of christ and then
all the peoples of the world and all of
time surrounding him and him sending out
his disciples out to go to the edges of
the world there's something you might
not have caught in this image i don't
know if you can catch it now maybe
if you take a little moment to look can
somebody see them
i'll help you out
and so the dog and men are represented
as monsters yes but as those who you can
commune with nonetheless
who are at least part of the potential
at the edge of the world which which we
can engage and which can hear
the message in some mysterious way which
can engage with you in some mysterious
way
and so this image is in france it's in
vesile
but there are also images of dog-headed
men in
eastern icons of pentecost
so this isn't this is an image from
armenia
so we can see can you see the dog in it
everybody can see the dog it in man
and we also have
a dog-headed
saint
this is an icon of saint christopher
so you might know saint christopher as
the patron saint of travelers
in the west he's represented as a giant
and he's mostly known for these little
medals that people wear when they're
traveling or else these little
statuettes that are on the dashboard of
cars you know people have these these
little statues of saint christopher
and in the west he's represented as this
giant but if you've been if you've been
paying attention to what i've been
saying it doesn't matter whether he's a
giant or a dog-headed man it doesn't
matter to the fact that he's a monster
just like those giants at the
at the edge of the flood in the story of
noah
and so the fact that he is the patron
saint of travelers should probably not
surprise us either
as we move away from our own home as we
move away from our own center no matter
what that is and we move out into the
unknown
our guide
our patron is this
holy monster
and the way he was represented in the
middle ages they relates to his function
as a monster in the greek tradition he
was often represented at at the above
the door of the church as you're leaving
the church so you would as you were
leaving the church the last icon you
would encounter would be this icon of
saint christopher
and in the west in the middle ages saint
christopher was represented on bridges
so that he could represent that in
between space
that indeterminate space that he lies
between categories
so i think
i think saint christopher is the patron
saint of the end of the world
that's my own opinion but i like to call
him that
so i want to i want to end my talk by
telling you a story telling you one of
the legends of saint christopher
so the most famous story of saint
christopher comes from the western
tradition
and it has sent christopher as a giant
canaanite and the canaanites are
basically these resid strange residues
of the descendants of kane
and so they were related to these giants
that were there before the flood in the
bible and so he's seen as part of this
group
who knows how they survive the flood
doesn't matter what's important is to
understand the symbolic relationship
between this character and these giants
that were there before the flood and so
he was this giant uh ferocious canaanite
and he decided
he was that he's a warrior you can see
that he's represented as a warrior and
so he said in his mind that he would
serve the most powerful king in the
world
and so he set out into the world to find
the most powerful king
so he comes to the court of the most
powerful king in the world and he starts
to serve this king
and then at some point he notices that
that the
king is afraid of the devil
and so
christopher asks the king he says who is
this devil
and the king doesn't want to tell him
right because the king
doesn't want him to leave but saint
christopher says no if you don't tell me
who the devil is then
i leave i'm going to leave and not serve
you anymore.
and so saint christopher tricks the king
because obviously
when the king tells him who the devil is
saint christopher immediately leaves and
goes to find the devil
so saint christopher finds the devil
and he starts to serve the devil
and then one day he notices that the
devil
as he's walking down the street
he avoids the cross
so christopher says oh there's something
going on there and he asked the devil it
says what is this cross why are you
afraid of the cross
and obviously the devil doesn't want to
tell him because he knows that saint
christopher will leave him
but saint christopher insists he says
unless you tell me what's the deal with
this cross then
i'm going to leave you
so saint christopher tricks the devil
and the devil tells him about christ so
saint christopher immediately leaves and
tries to find christ
so as he's out there trying to find
christ he comes upon a monk
and the monk tells him he said i'll show
you the ways of christianity so the monk
tell us that christopher well you
you should you should fast and say
christopher says no i can't i can't fast
so the monk tells saint christopher then
you should pray and say christopher says
no i can't can't pray
i mean
he's a monster after all
and so the monk
tells saint christopher
to stand
on the side of the river
and to cross whoever asks him to cross
right now i need you to remember
from the beginning of what i said
this image of the world
right this image of the world going to
the flood this image of the island going
to the ocean so saint christopher stands
on the edge of the world
he stands on the edge of the flood
and then suddenly one day
this young child
comes to see him
this
young child obviously the weakest thing
you can think of
the child asks saint christopher to help
him cross
the river
so saint christopher puts him on his
shoulder
and he starts to cross him over the
river
and as he's crossing the child becomes
heavier and heavier and heavier and said
christopher is struggling to hold the
child up above the waters
and at some point it feels like the
whole world is on his
shoulders but he manages to cross the
river and comes to the other side and
then he asks the child he says why
were you so heavy
and the child answers because i was
carrying the sins of the world
and so
christ tricks
saint christopher
into serving him
the smallest then the weakest thing the
seed this
tricks and christopher into serving him
so i think that's really the last image
i want to leave you with especially as
we
we go towards
those of you who are christian and are
in length we're moving towards
the
passion of christ for the death of
christ and the resurrection
just just one maybe one little last
thing do you
one of the things i'm trying to
do when i give these talks try to help
people see the patterns
so
this story this child
on the back of this monster
what is it
uh answer to
what puzzle does it solve
that i presented at the beginning
it solves this puzzle
here's the dead child and the writhing
beast
but in the story of christ that's the
difference between the story the poem of
yeast is that we don't have this idea of
just the falconer standing in the middle
and calling out to the falconer we have
this notion of the seed this
this image of moving out all the way to
the edge and that's the story of easter
moving out all the way down into the
bottom of death
and then
living in the hope of the resurrection
and so the story of saint christopher
what it really is about
is about the possibility of the
resurrection
coming out
of death
it's the
solution
to the zombie apocalypse so
thank you
[Applause]
so i don't know if i think there's going
to be questions later but we're a bit
late i don't know if there are people
who have quick
would you be questions
in some way that the
so-called zombie phrase
society even the past second one zombie
movie after another
is somehow
self-image of the unconscious
representing feelings of society
and then with that especially the
zombie christ in america today
would you say that's representative of
america somehow going on a path forward
yes i think that's what it is i think so
that was
well put
i do think that the zombie narrative
especially the fact that it appears on
the horizon so powerfully and especially
because it is a new trope
there is no real equivalent for the
zombie apocalypse in traditional stories
this unending wave after wave of zombie
maybe the closest thing to the zombie
apocalypse we have is the let's say the
horde the barbarian hordes that might be
the closest thing of something that
comes in and levels baghdad with no
desire you know to preserve anything
they just want to return it to dust you
know so there is there maybe is a little
bit of that but i think that this this
appearance of the zombie is really
important john vervaca the this this
this scholar you can look up his book
online it's free that he published it
for free and so it's a really
interesting analysis of the zombie and
how he's a he's a psychologist and it is
a very very powerful analysis of how uh
it is a trope which manifests the loss
of meaning and nihilism in in the
contemporary world but john rebecca he
i think one thing that he misses and he
sees it as a fragmentation of the
christian worldview and i think that
he's right that that's what it is but
the one thing he misses is he misses
that the narrative of christianity
contains within itself its own
destruction
and that's something that he doesn't
address in his book christianity
contains in its own story its own
destruction and its resurrection
right and so you see it in the story of
christ
like that he chose his own betrayer and
and christ is the trade he dies and he
resurrects then you can see it in the
the projection in in the prophecies
about the notion of the spirit of
antichrist which rises out of
christianity i mean you can't have
antichrist comes from has to come from
christianity the antichrist obviously
isn't chinese that doesn't make any
sense that the spirit of antichrist has
to come from within christianity and
then christianity
destroys itself
and
then yeah i don't know
we can live in the hope of the
resurrection i would say
wow that's not an easy question that's a
really complicated question
i would say i would say the best way to
do it is to pay attention to
[Music]
to look at you look at the stories and
then you look at especially the stories
you look at the stories and you try to
figure out what are the connections
between the stories and when i say
stories it's not just the stories in the
bible but but the the same patterns that
are there in the bible are there in
fairy tales they're there and stories
from other cultures they're they're
they're they're basically the fabric of
of the world and so paying attention and
looking for the places where they
connect i also it's especially if you're
talking coming out of christianity
let's say as
a christian one of the things i tell
people is is to pay attention to the
apocryphal apocryphal stories pay
attention to the traditions that came
after the text
because
the reason for those stories is usually
to help you see some connections that
you hadn't seen before
or that are there suggested in the text
but that you don't but that you don't
necessarily realize so the the biggest
example that i give is for example the
idea that in the in the nativity of
christ there was an ax an ass and an ox
and that is not in the bible but it's
there from the beginning of christianity
the first images we have of the birth of
christ show this
this this this ass and this ox at the
at the at the crib and so
the the idea is what is happening and so
that was added but it's there to help
you see that no this connects to these
other places in the text and ultimately
it connects
i'm not going to go into the whole
string but it actually connects to the
notion of the cherub
on the ark of the covenant these two
beasts that are on the ark of the
covenant and so the the manger becomes
the box in which the divine glory is set
and the two beasts act as the the two
guardians of the of the box and so to
add that detail and there's other things
going on at the same time the union of
the jew and the gentile is also
happening with the pure animal and an
impure animal there are all these things
going on but usually the if you look at
the addition uh the additional stories
that the what happens in between the the
stories that we know you can you can it
can help you to see the patterns that
might be one strategy
yeah
um
[Music]
of what we've lost as a culture and it
really makes sense when you're talking
about churches
and the outside would kind of shatter
all this be coupled together
and with uh saint christopher being
tricked into being back you know those
of us who are christians we have this
idea
and
in
comic books in culture in movies
hmm
you mean in the story of saint
christopher
right
well what do you do you get you have
stories
you know the story of pinocchio is this
is a story of an artificial creature who
is not real who's uh who's a puppet
who's on the edge who's who's hanging by
strings you want to understand an image
of the edge you can understand the
falconer holding the the string and then
the puppet you know on the edge of that
string i'm mixing metaphors hopefully
you know you see why i'm doing it and so
the story pinocchio is a story of that
transformation from the artificial and
the edge to the center there are other
stories i i did a review on my youtube
channel recently of the movie logan i
think that's a perfect example of that
story of a monster
who becomes human and ascends the
mountain and then comes to eden right
and so it really is
it uses a very powerful christian
symbolism to show this transformation of
the monster into a human who finally
sacrifices himself
and is hung on a tree you know i mean
the imagery is so layered thick in that
movie in terms of of finding the monster
kind of coming back and and serving the
the center let's say acting as a
guardian as well
yeah
um
[Music]
yeah i don't i don't
i never totally i haven't studied
the whole phenomena of of the dragon in
in asia i don't know enough about it to
talk about it but what i would say is
that it's is that there are positive and
negative monsters in the west too
right i showed you an image of the
griffin for example the griffin als
always had a positive association with
it this notion of of a joining of heaven
and earth a bird and uh and a lion these
two you know an eagle and a lion's two
royal figures one from above one from
below joined together into one amalgam
as creature so the griffin has a
positive aspect even though it also acts
as a guardian
for uh can act as a guardian for a holy
place and actually someone someone uh
pointed out to me that the word griffin
is a cognate of cherubim that it's
actually the same letters just a
transformation of the same letters and
so they probably have very very far away
they have a similar similar root and so
and the cherubim also has that that
characteristic
so so i think that the dragon definitely
is seen in negative terms and the dragon
also
in the west has that has that function
but we can see both sides
i think so
[Applause]
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism get involved i
love to read your comments in the
comments section below
please go ahead and share this on social
media to all your friends and also
please consider supporting us
financially on patreon you'll find the
link to the patreon page in the
description below